alex jones i believe wants to get on he
uh feels uh that he has a
particular take on the election that
people need to hear and since he's been
thrown off of
all the major media he wants to get his
word out i think in
in all fairness we should let him have a
word really you think
that's right there he is alex jones alex
go ahead
infowars.com
we are witnessing the 100
reptilian rigged election it's a
globalist coup
it has been coordinated by communist
china big tech and now
lord biden the communist pedophile china
chai com
agent wants to bury your ballots delay
the results of the election knowing that
donald trump wins
infowars.com now uh
you're making a lot of accusations i
don't even know where to begin i i think
what you're saying
is what infowars.com
listen we need to prepare now for what
the globalists have planned which is
the 79 days of hell i told you donald
trump's gonna win big the democrats are
gonna contest it they want a planetary
reset
they don't want a pro-human future the
four horsemen called for the u.n
takeover the davos group is gonna take
over they said
the viral release is phase one now we
enter the war games
of phase two infowars.com how do we draw
you bringing up a viral infection a
pandemic
before the pandemic actually started
well i've been saying this
since day one i've lost three of my
molars from clenching my teeth over the
past few weeks over this i've fallen out
like 10 years old
there goes three more listen i only pray
to god that donald trump has the
strength to defeat these demons
because fouchy gates and sorrows they
are anti you
[Music]
are you crying
[Music]
they want a question as they want to
keep this locked out going
alex you said you it control yourself i
i
said the uh you said the democrats the
democrats are anti-human uh what is that
about
this is a foreign war
is over they want to normalize
centralized control psychological
algorithms they want to take us
bill gates was on epstein island we have
the plane tickets we can see the martial
law power grip we know this
listen danfo warriors are not taking it
anymore
they are riding in they're mad at the
globalists and they're still mad at my
tank driver who did not reveal who he
voted for here i'll read you something
for warrior feedback here
alex your tank driver is globalist scum
hillary clinton offered to finally admit
to being reptilian
and it still didn't sway him not a team
player maybe he should drive
soros's tank well you know alex
step up that's what i said i had a
similar problem my my uh
ronnie the limo driver would not tell me
who he was voting for and your tank
driver will not tell you who he's voting
for
it's a serious problem listen people are
down with the mainstream psyop they want
to vote for queen demon hillary clinton
and lord biden and they want to push the
stockholm syndromes
on people the communist overlord biden
is going to try and inoculate you
with the experimental synthetic nanotech
antibodies right
do not fall for the antibody cocktail
when they give it to you do you know
what you need
which will save you from globalist
overture what
the alpha male
mind milk cocktail that's right it's our
strongest supplement on the market
full of b vitamins probiotics x9 enzymes
lighter fluid
also doubles as of like
you're going to love it clean your oven
with it buy now get a free arrest
fouchy hoodie footy that's a double deal
steal of a deal
double value deal of a deal
wars.com listen
that's enough i gotta go take a piss
maybe after this i'm to bring the guys
in
i want to hear what uh owen troyer and
david knight were up to last night how
they dealt with the election
i got to get going infowars.com do not
believe the globalists do not believe
the manipulation of google they want to
plunge the economy
it is the globalist model and alex
before you go just
alex why are we arresting fauci again
fauci
runs the chinese death camps with tim
cook look the governor of california
already said we're going to inject 11
year olds with vaccines we're going to
give them abortions without consent
these are weird sick twisted freakazoids
they want to give people hiv and that's
what they've been doing all this time
arrest vouching arrest gates
infowars.com
[Music]
yeah i don't want lots of people to get
to hear him
you